Cleaning, checking and counting OCD are the most common types of OCD and it
interferes with normal functioning of daily life. For example, a person with
OCD who fears germs is going to spend an excessive amount of time worrying
about germs. They're going to be thinking about all the germs that surround
them. Worrying about touching something and acquiring new germs. Now these
anxious thoughts that they have are combated by the compulsive behaviors that
they engage in. For example, a person who's afraid of germs may wash their
hands two to 300 times a day in scolding hot water. Or perhaps they wash them
five to six times a day, but for 30 to 40 minutes at a time. The person is
aware of these compulsions but they're unable to stop them. A person with
checking OCD, may have to check the stove repeatedly before leaving the house
to make sure it's off even though they haven't cooked at home in months. And
finally a person with counting OCD maybe has to touch a doorknob 14 times for
fear that his dog will die if he doesn't. Even though he knows there's really
no connection between how many times he touches a door knob and the fate of his
dog. So the main thing to remember is that the person is aware of these
compulsions, but they're still unable to stop them.